aquí en Java entre los escombros son
muchos los que intentan encontrar a sus
familiares y seres queridos como Aris de
45 años que estaba de camino a casa de
su hermano y su cuñada cuando sintió el
terremoto de magnitud 5,6 en la escala
richterra
estoy aquí porque Necesito encontrar a
mi familia a mi cuñada quedó sepultada
bajo este derrumbe eran tres mi cuñada y
sus dos hijos cuando llegué ayer no
quedaba nada Todo estaba enterrado bajo
tierra
Y es que el terremoto que se produjo el
lunes en la mañana causó un
deslizamiento de tierras que ha
sepultado al menos a un pueblo entero
ahora los trabajadores de emergencia se
apresuran a despejar las zonas afectadas
para intentar rescatar a los
supervivientes mientras en las
autoridades confirmaron que entre los
fallecidos hay muchos menores de edad
cuyas escuelas colapsaron durante el
sismo
he ordenado la movilización de personal
para ayudar a los esfuerzos de rescate
tras el terremoto también he ordenado
que se priorice la búsqueda de víctimas
y la evacuación de supervivientes
esfuerzos que sean complicado debido a
los cortes de Electricidad y las
carreteras dañadas en la provincia de
Java occidental donde al menos 13.000
personas ya han sido evacuadas y cerca
de 2.200 casas han quedado destruidas
me puse a llorar e inmediatamente agarré
a mi marido y a mis hijos Si no los
acaba podríamos habernos convertido
víctimas la casa temblaba como si
estuviera bailando en medio del conocido
como anillo del fuego por su actividad
es sísmica debido al choque de placas
tectónicas y Indonesia tiene un amplio
historia de terremotos fenómenos
destinados a repetirse periódicamente